[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
elias hat die hose noch an und die
brille auf und jetzt gleich jetzt ab und
freunde
wichtig ist dass er den pullover rechten
seite nicht mitnimmt sowohl das auto als
auch der elias so und jetzt 12 als
wahnsinn
also das muss man wirklich sagen und ja
wichtig ist auch nicht in den wagen
darauf verlinken seite mitzunehmen oder
sieht ganz gut aus
sagen wir jetzt ungefähr 7 km h auf dem
tacho so jetzt links dran vorbei und
sensationell ist aber hier die die fans
jubeln
so entstand kurz ich stand kurz aber
dann geht es leider nicht runter damit
man wieder speed krieg auch weiterfahren
kann dass es halt hier leider nicht die
optimale piste ja aber schon schon ein
bisschen wahnsinnig oder braucht auf
jeden fall super spaß okay du gehst
gymnasiast eigentlich heute schule
gehabt was hast du da erzählt ja das
stimmt ich habe ja danke sehr hans jaich
haben einfach gesagt dass ich gleich
hier bei videodrehs habe und ein paar
coole sachen machen spaß
was hat der lehrer gesagt er meinte erst
neidisch dass er arbeiten muss aber
freut sich für mich und wie ist das mit
weiteren anfragen musste die schule
jetzt schmeißen weil du professionell
stunts maß ich glaube schon also ich
glaube da führt kein weg vorbei
scherz ich mache natürlich jetzt noch
mal wie fertig auch ein keppler genau
ich finde auch schülersprecher da kann
ich ja nicht einfach weggehen
ja ich sag mal wenn die schüler so gut
vertrieben werden wie der wieder elias
hier heute seinen sport dann kann
eigentlich nichts anderem
man darf natürlich nicht vergessen dass
es auch mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur weil bild schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren